the Joe Rogan experience hardly anybody
is religious really what are the numbers
apart from immigrant Muslims who still
are but among them I don't know that
they're pathetically small is there any
evidence that that is reaching the
Muslim world as well and that people are
well as I was saying the the downloads
of of my books have been encouraging we
have this thing called CFI has a thing
called the translation project which is
specifically in order to do that in
order to to take my books and we hope
other people's books as well and put
them into PDFs and then have them
available for free download and I hear
evidence from Iran from Egypt from Saudi
Arabia from individuals who say yes
there's now quite a substantial
groundswell of anti religious
anti-islamic opinion and I think is
going to increase and I'm really
encouraged by that one of the things
about being Muslim in my eyes it's very
similar to being Jewish is that Jewish
people in there it's there are many
Jewish people that are not religious but
they are Jewish like I have a very good
friend my friend Ari he is he is Jewish
but he is an atheist and it's he
identifies with being a Jewish person he
has Jewish relatives his father is a
Holocaust survivor but he looks at it
like a thing that he's a part of like a
great long tradition he's a part of but
he doesn't observe no I understand that
I think especially for people of Jewish
heritage who have relatives killed in
the Holocaust I think it could be a
matter of kind of loyalty to their
murdered relatives mm-hmm I could easily
get that and I think that there are
probably cultural Muslims who probably
not for the same degree of loyalty but
police think of themselves as Muslims I
suppose I meant cultural Anglican in the
way I mean I sort of you know I can sing
the hymns and and I
my family observes Christmas and as a
result away when someone sneezes do you
say bless you I never did say bless you
actually but right
I never does anything but I've no
objection to saying cuz I'd open because
that was religious but not religious but
they my college at Oxford
had a fella who was a famous philosopher
a famous atheist a Jair and he when he
was senior fellow he used to say grace
at dinner and when he was asked why he
said I will not utter falsehoods but I
have no objection to uttering
meaningless statements
[Laughter]
[Applause]